hello everyone and welcome to round 8 of
the 2018 Tata Steel chess tournament
here we had Magnus Carlsen with the
white pieces playing against English
grandmaster and order
Gawain Jones going Jones won last year's
Tata Steel challengers tournament so he
qualified for this year's Master
tournament as you all know there are two
tournaments in vikon's
the Tata Steel masters and Tata Steel
challengers so he won last year
challengers and now he's playing with
the big boys and here he faces Magnus
Carlsen like the title suggests it's a
very interesting game and the action
begins really early but it also shows
that not everything is always as it
seems so Carson has the white pieces and
he opens up with E 4 we have c5 the
Sicilian defence Knight to f3 d6 d4 C
captures Knight captures Knight to f6
and Knight to c3 and we have g6 Jones
goes for the dragon variation Bishop to
e3 Bishop to g7 + f3 now Karsten starts
the Yugoslavia tag preparing you know
pawn to g4 point to h4
and so on Knight to c6 Queen to d2 and
now King said castle by Jones queenside
castle by Carlsen and d5 and here are
Carlsen decides to play although there
are a lot of options here you can go for
a series of exchanges Carson goes for
Queen to e1 I will just show one
variation because it includes a queen
sacrifice for white so just so you know
it if you ever want to play it if you
play for example Knight captures then
you have B captures and you capture on
d5 Knight captures Knight captures pawn
captures and Queen captures and b5 and
it seems white 1 upon and is also
attacking the rook on a8 but here black
can go Queen to c7 white captures the
rook and now Bishop to f5 threatening
checkmate
and c2 and here white gives up a Queen
Queen captures on f8 King captures and
now rook to d2 and if you look at this
position white has two rooks for the
Queen both players have the bishop pair
and white is also up upon so this
position is considered to be equal if
you ever wanna maybe play it use it as a
surprise you have to really know what
you're doing
here obviously Crossin doesn't go for
anything like this after d5 he plays
Queen to e1 we have E 5 now and Knight
captures on c6 this is basically your
only move that you can play here if you
try something like Knight to b3 you get
to d4 and it's not that you're losing
losing a piece you can simply play
Bishop to g5 and why can't capture the
point is pinned to Rockwell will capture
the Queen
but after Bishop to b6 preventing the
knight from jumping to d5 it's it's an
excellent position for black regardless
of you know him not winning a piece so
after a 5 Knight captures on c6 this is
the best move we have B captures on c6
and it captures on d5 and here probably
the best move for black is C captures on
d5 you fix your pawn structure you allow
this Bishop to be developed freely Jones
goes for Knight captures here on on d5
and here Carlsen goes for Bishop to c4
pinning that night the night is now
attacked three times and also it's
pinned that the rock is still eyeing
that Queen and e8 and as I say in the
game it this will prove to be very
difficult to unpin for Jones Bishop to
e6 defending the knight as it was
attacked three times and King to be one
we have rook to e8 and Knight to e4 now
with f5 Knight to g5 and Bishop to c8
not allowing the knight to capture the
bishop of course and it's a it's
definitely a great position for Carlsen
he has the white pieces he's definitely
ready to pull those pawns the knight on
d5 is pinned twice it can't move because
the Queen will be attacked and also it
will be checked from Google on c4 and
here would remove like h4 everything is
great for Carson he's defending the
knight and on g5 also now is definitely
ready to pull those pawns but here after
this Bishop to c8 move across and played
g4 and this g4 move actually loses a
piece and it's not it's not that
difficult to see why it lives it's a
piece here Jones simply pushed f4
now the Queen is attacking the knight
and g5 and also the f4 pawn is attacking
the bishop on III and the bishop on e3
was actually protecting the night on g5
so naturally instead of g4 h for
defending the night would have been a
preferred move but if you look at this
it I mean this here this g4 move it
blunders a piece but also it it really
looks like a very nice style move so
it's hard to say I mean I'm sure croc
awesome blunder the piece here he didn't
go for a towel move as I saw a photo of
him on Twitter where he after he made
this move and he saw a force he was very
maybe was not happy but okay he goes h4
he doesn't really have a lot to think of
think about here he has to go all out
you know justify losing the piece Jones
plays F captures on e3 and we have Queen
captures on e3 the knight on d5 is still
pinned h6 kicking away the night and
here we have Queen to c5 and here
Jones already want a piece so does he
really want to grab another piece that's
the question what happens if he grabs
the piece if he grabs the night on g5 h
captures and g5 he gets Queen captures
on c6 attacking the rook on a8 there's a
triple attack now on the knight on d5
the queen is attacking the pawn on d6
Carson would be ready to play H captors
and g5 with temple so this would result
in a very forced variation Bishop to e6
and now the queen is defending the rook
also the bishop is now adding more
protection to the night so after Bishop
captures Bishop captures rook captures
and Queen to b6 offering an exchange of
Queens queen to c4 probably threatening
some nasty discoveries Queen to e6 and
now H captures and g5 and black is
better here I mean that piece up is
still a piece up but Jones decides not
to go for this so after this Queen to c5
moved by Carlsen he plays Bishop to b7
now connecting all all the heavy pieces
on the back rank and defending the c6
pawn with the bishop Carson goes Knight
to e4 gets his Knight out of harm's way
and here we have rook to X adding some
more protect
Toodee spawns not allowing ideas like
night study six but sorry but there were
some other moves possible here
perhaps Quint a king to h8 unpinning
from this nasty pin and also moves like
Bishop to f8 were possible harassing the
Queen and c5 but okay he goes for rook
to e6
we have h5 by Carlsen
and here we have Queen to b6 offering an
exchange of Queens and here we have a
beautiful move by Carlson one that you
really you know have to find in
positions like this because it's you
know black is still better you don't
want to make any any moves that aren't
the best moves here cousin pushes g5 and
what do you do here it seems like this
is a great opportunity for Jones to
maybe exchange Queens but that would
actually lose the game immediately if
you play something like Queen captures
you get Knight captures on c5 attacking
the rook on d6 and the bishop on b7 if
you defend the bishop you get Knight
captures rook captures and now simply
rook captures on d5 winning the piece
back and now white is simply better of
course you can't exchange because the
bishop grabs it with to check you move
the King you lose another rook and after
the rook moves simply now for example
three for pinning that pawn and after
pawn captures pawn captures King moves
they are opposite colored bishops but
there were rook still in the game and
Carlson is up two points and they are
very well protected two points so black
can never do anything to capture these
pawns and the Queen side majority owned
majority will be too much for black to
handle so this would be winning for
Carlsen
so after this g5 move probably the best
idea is is Bishop to f8 because mission
to f8 now attacks the Queen of course
capturing mb6 favors black so this
forces an exchange of Queens after Queen
g1 Queen captures and rook captures
black would still be up a piece he would
have a better position but it's hard to
say the bishop in b7 isn't really a
really a star this rock is still
undeveloped those rooks on g1 and h1 are
eyeing that King and g8 so definitely
not a simple position to handle and
Jones was a very long time he was like
he was like 16 minutes and Carson had
like 45 minutes so after this g5 move no
capturing the Queen no Bishop to f8 was
played Jones plays H captures on g5 and
this gives Carlsen our return into the
game he plays Queen to a3 not allowing
black to exchange any pieces and we have
rook to b8
now Jones is preparing to move this
bishop or temple also threatened that B
to pawn
we have b3 and if you look at this
position now black doesn't have a beep
on and black doesn't have a deep on so
he can never harass this bishop on c4
with a pawn and this bishop will be a
great defender he completely defends
cross and Queen side and he's pinning
all of blacks pieces so this bishop on
c4
that's definitely Carson strongest piece
that's that's a monster bishop so we
have Queen to d8
here preparing a move like Queen to e7
maybe to exchange Queens this way and
I've seen commentators even Sokolov and
Eric Hanson they were they were
analyzing a move rook D to G 1 but seems
like Queen to e7 Saul's all blacks all
blacks problems but here Carlsen goes
for the best move he plays Queen
captures an a7 now pressuring the rockin
b8 as the rockin b8 is only defended by
the Queen on the 8th so this forces the
Queen to stay on the back rank we have G
captures on h5 rod captures on h5 and
now rock to g6 trying to defend that
pawn and not trying to defend the pawn
of course the pawn cannot be defended as
the Queen is you know she has to protect
the pawn and the rockin b8 so the point
isn't really protected but the rook will
be useful after a roof like a move like
rope to g1 is played so rook after Sun
g5 by Carlsen rook captures and night
after Sun g5 now the Queen can capture
the night as we've said Queen captures
rockin b8 so Quinta c8 protecting the
bishop on
b7 so rook to eight can be played
kicking the Queen away
Carson goes for rook to g1 we have rook
to 8 and now Queen to b6 and as you can
see for the entire game Carson is very
you know very creatively using the idea
that this knight on d5 is pinned for the
entire game
rook to a6 kicking the Queen even
further back and Queen to c5 and we have
Queen to d7 here Knight to e4 and this
Knight to e4 comes with some terrible
threats of course the idea is Knight to
f6 check the bishop on g7 is pin from
the rook the knight on d5 is pin from
the bishop on c4 so this would
definitely fork the king and the Queen
and win the game King to h8 on pin are
you getting out of the way and we have
Queen to f2 now and Queen to e7
unfortunately you can't do anything
about this rook on a6 being attacked if
you play anything like rook to e8
then you lose to the previous variation
simply Queen to h2 King has to move and
now Knight to f6 for the king and the
Queen both night and bishop are still
pinned so after Queen to e2 Queen to e7
getting the Queen out of that nasty
Square and we have Bishop captures on a6
grabbing the rook Bishop captures and
now Queen to h2 check King to g8 and now
Queen to h6 again taking advantage of
Jones pieces being pinned we have Queen
to a7 and now Queen to e6 check King to
f8 and now Rock to g5 preparing of
course rook rook to f5 check and this
will be this will be winning for white
so 933 defending f5 and we have Queen to
d6 check King moves and here we have
United c5 and again a lot of threats
here for white you simply can't stop all
of them here the basic threat is going
to e6 check King moves to f8 and then
Knight to d7 check the King has nowhere
to go
white wins the Queen and the game here
Jones played Bishop to c8 and here
cousin played game winning move
feel free to for free
to pause the position and try and find a
move it's it's not a complicated move
maybe at a three move combination so
feel free to do it for those of you who
managed to find the move congratulations
you're a great player and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Carlson played rook captures and g7 this
is what check you don't really have the
option of not capturing the rook because
the rook would also be attacking the
Queen on a 7 so here King captures and
simply Queen captures on e5 checking the
King and attacking the knight on e3 King
moves Queen captures on e3 now defending
the knight and c5 you want the piece
back you are up three points and there
is no point in continuing this game
going Jones resigned the game after this
beautiful rook captures and g7 so once
again congratulations for those of you
who found it and how does this affect it
affect the rankings it seems that now
Carlsen giri and chakra mama dro are
both are all three of them tied for
first place with five and a half points
since Geary defeated Momiji are up in
round eight it was a very nice game
wasn't wasn't even that that complicated
giri just had a better position and he
crushed my media roof so now three of
them have five and a half points and it
will be a very very tied you know
tournament so yeah that's the game I
think all of the games are finished
while I'm making this video who even is
still playing her game against Fabiano
Caruana so maybe we'll see maybe we'll
see a shift of luck for her there so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank James
Scalise for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
and I would like to thank all of you for
your contributions yeah bitcoin and
litecoin although I have no way of
knowing who you are but thank you of
course as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here they will both be
from the Tata Steel chess tournament I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon probably put another video from
the tata steel chess tournament